[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Good afternoon, everybody,
and thank you for joining us
and the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the
Institute, and I am
delighted to welcome you today
to our conference on women
in biotech.
The Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study
is a unique
intellectual community
where scholars, scientists,
and artists work
at the forefront of
their disciplines
and across academic boundaries.
It fosters an
intellectual climate
of both daring and
rigor, characteristics
that are shared with the
fast-evolving field of biotech.
At Radcliffe, we are also
deeply committed to sharing
advanced work with the
public through conferences
like this one.
We at Radcliffe are proud
of our rich tradition
of programming in the sciences.
That tradition hearkens
back to Mary Ingram Bunting,
the fifth president
of Radcliffe College
and founder of our forerunner,
the Radcliffe Institute
for Independent Study.
Bunting was a microbiologist.
More recently, my
predecessor as dean
was a computer
scientist, Barbara Gross,
who I'm so pleased to
have with us here today.
I also want to acknowledge
and extend sincere thanks
to Dr. Nancy Hopkins of MIT.
Nancy, who's also here
in attendance today,
inspired this
conference, just as she
has inspired and encouraged
women in the sciences
through her life and her work.
I also want to thank
our panelists, who
have come from lecture
halls, labs, and boardrooms
to think about women in
biotech with us today.
Radcliffe's deep
commitment to the sciences
manifests itself in a
number of ways this fall.
We have many
impressive scientists
among the year's 50 fellows.
Our annual science
symposium will
consider the past,
present, and future of DNA
on Friday, October 2.
And we will continue
our inquiry into
genetic and
microbiological questions
over the course of this academic
year with our science lecture
series.
You can see these events and
many more of our fall offerings
listed on the calendar
cards that we've
placed on your chairs.
And we also encourage you
to check out our website
to keep apprised of the
many opportunities we
offer to engage with
interesting, important, and
timely issues.
The topic of biotech is
intriguing for many reasons.
Since Stanford scientist
Herbert Boyer teamed up
with venture capitalist
Robert Swanson in 1976
to found the
Genentech Corporation,
biotech has been at the nexus of
cutting-edge laboratory science
and venture capital.
The commercialization of
recombinant DNA technology
has altered relationships
between universities,
government, and industry.
In our daily lives,
it has changed
and will continue to change
in profound ways how we eat,
how we grow things,
and how we heal.
Another reason that biotech
is an exciting field
is that there are women
in leadership positions,
and there have been
from the very beginning.
When H. Stewart Parker
graduated from the University
of Washington in
1981, she was hired
as the very first employee
of the Immunex Corporation
in Seattle.
From that start, she went on
to serve the biotech industry
as vice president of corporate
development, president, CEO,
director, chairman,
and lobbyist.
Her career makes
the point that right
from the start of the
biotechnology industry, there
have been women leading it.
I know that we have some of
them in the audience here today,
and we will hear from
others as we listen
to this afternoon's panels.
But how many are there?
In 2001, a study revealed
that women made up about 10%
of senior leadership
in top biotech firms.
That study acknowledged that
the number was a little low.
But it also exuded
confidence that, with so many
scientifically talented
women in the pipeline,
those numbers were sure to soar.
In some ways numbers
have climbed.
More women than men now attend
college, more women than men
study biology at the
undergraduate and graduate
levels, and more than half
of all biology PhDs today
are earned by women.
Women are not as
well represented
on science faculties
and universities,
but they make up an
increasing proportion
at the assistant rank.
So 26% of biology
faculty at MIT are women.
At Harvard, women constitute
30% of tenured and tenure
track biology professors
within the faculty of Arts
and Sciences.
While all these changes have
been happening in academia,
the practice of
science itself has
been altering in some other
quite significant ways.
Most notably,
scientific research
has been increasingly
privatized and commercialized.
What that means is that today's
most significant advances are
just as likely to happen in
a privately owned lab geared
toward profit as they are
in a nonprofit, educational,
or governmental setting.
Corporate, particularly
venture capital sponsorship,
means that big
breakthroughs and big money
are now very likely to be
made in the same place.
So how many women
are in that place?
How have all the
optimistic predictions
made in 2001, that the
10% percent number was
about to take off, panned out?
Well, a study of
senior leadership
in top biotech firms in
2014 found that women
comprise-- are you ready-- 10%.
Where that 10% can be
found is also revealing.
Massachusetts Biotech
Research Council data
showed that most senior
women are in communications,
human resources, and
development-- important roles
to be sure, but still not
the same as directors,
chief financial officers,
or chief executives.
Studies show that
the absence of women
does not arise from any lack
of ambition on women's parts,
and this is very important.
In a 2014 survey of
industry leaders,
equal percentages
of men and women
identified being named to
a board as a personal goal.
Yet, while 59% of
the men surveyed
had been invited to join a
board, only 16% of the women
had.
But don't worry, the
2014 study assures us.
There are so many talented
women in the pipeline
that the numbers are
about to skyrocket.
The numbers we're supposed
to do that in 2001.
But now, almost a
decade and a half
later, they still have not.
So where are all those eagerly
awaited women in biotech?
Thanks to the work
of Nancy Hopkins,
we have learned that they are
not on boards of directors
or on scientific
advisory boards.
Hopkins used data from a
Kauffman Family Foundation
report to demonstrate that only
about 5% to 8% of those bodies
consist of women.
So what is stopping up
this pipeline of women
in the biotech industry?
One recent incident that got
a lot of press offers a clue.
Dr. Tim Hunt of the
UK holds a Nobel Prize
in physiology and medicine
for his work on cell division.
At the World Conference
of Science Journalists
in South Korea this
past June, Dr. Hunt
stated publicly that--
and I'm quoting him--
"girls were nothing but
trouble in science."
And here's what he said.
"Three things happen when
they are in the lab.
You fall in love with them,
they fall in love with you,
and when you criticize
them they cry."
End quote.
Well, that kind of
attitude could well
be part of what is blocking
the promised pipeline.
Women facing
prejudice in science
is not a new topic, of
course, and concern about it
is not new either.
In 1994, the journal Science
ran a three-part series on women
in science.
At that time, editor-in-chief
Daniel E. Koshland reflected,
and I'm quoting him,
"Although many formal barriers
to women's participation
in science have fallen,
cultural attitudes and
antagonism remain."
Nobel Laureate Hunt certainly
proves that statement
to be true.
Koshland further wondered
more than 20 years ago
in another quote,
"if society can
afford to be underutilize
the abilities of half
of its citizens."
More recently, a
team of researchers
led by Laurel Smith-Doerr,
who's here with us
today, found that, and I
quote, "Women are currently,
and have historically
been, underrepresented
in top leadership positions in
biotech policymaking, research,
and management.
Without equal input
from both men and women
in decision-making, solutions
to today's intractable problems
are unlikely to be optimal."
Even more bluntly,
the study warned,
and I quote, "We are missing
out on talented leadership
and on diversity
in leadership that
could be readily achieved."
Missing out indeed.
A recent independent report
entitled "The Bottom Line--
Corporate Performance and
Women's Representation
on Boards" found that
companies, including Fortune 500
companies, with three or
more women on their boards
outperformed their counterparts
with fewer women in all ways,
including financial success.
That evidence deserves
a wide hearing,
and it is likely that one of the
significant pressures keeping
women out of biotech boardrooms
is the dependence of startups
on venture capitalists, who
may take risks in certain areas
but who are risk adverse in
others like gender equity.
Let's make sure that money
talks in this conversation.
We seem, in conclusion,
to be facing
a clear problem of
talent under-utilization
in the burgeoning
world of biotech.
No field, no country,
no society can
afford to squander the talents
of half of its population.
Science certainly cannot.
At Radcliffe, we have known
that to be true all the way back
to the days of Mary Bunting.
So what better place
to ask questions
about where women in biotech
have been, where they are now,
and where we want them
to be in 10 years time?
I hope we will leave this room
today not only with a deeper
understanding of the obstacles
to women's participation,
but also with new insight into
how we can turn things around.
To get our conversation started,
I'd now like to hand things
over to Professor Dan Carpenter.
Dan is the faculty director
of social science programs
at the Radcliffe Institute, and
he is also the Allie S. Freed
Professor of Government in the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences.
So, Dan.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you, Liz.
I'm proud that Radcliffe today
hosts a conversation that
brings some of the best
and brightest minds
from academia, industry,
and other domains
to talk about a critical
problem facing not only
our system of science but also
our economy and one of its most
important industries.
Dean Cohen has just outlined
the parameters of that problem,
and you're going to
hear much, much more
in the hours that follow.
We at Radcliffe
recognize, of course,
that the gender gap in
biotech is a complex problem,
and that the facts on
the ground are changing
as we meet and speak today.
Our panelists
indeed are also well
aware of the fluid
nature of this problem,
and of course of the enduring
structural disparities that
continue to shape the
biotechnology industry.
The Radcliffe Institute excels
at the interdisciplinary.
There's a lot of talk
at various universities
about breaking out
of boxes, busting out
of silos, a lot of talk about
the importance of getting
interdisciplinary.
But in my 20-year
experience in the academy,
there is not a single place that
does it as well as Radcliffe.
And that's the kind
of event that we're
going to bring to you today.
Some of the panelists
you will hear from today
are life scientists who
have had scientific training
and experiences in the life
sciences industry for decades.
The social science panelists
you will hear today
are trained sociologists,
psychologists, and management
specialists, and
they have themselves
spent decades studying
this industry in-depth
and others like it.
We're going to hear from
scientists, but also
from those who study the
careers of scientists.
We're going to hear from biotech
entrepreneurs, but also those
who study, systematically
and with very granular data,
the operations and successes
or failures of biotech firms.
Before turning to
the first panel,
let me transition
by way of a story.
I've written some on the
Food and Drug Administration
and on food and drug law and
the regulations governing
the pharmaceutical and
biotechnology industries,
in a few years ago I had
the privilege of serving
on the United States
Institute of Medicine,
or IOM, committee
examining issues
in the pharmaceutical industry.
The report was commissioned
by the Food and Drug
Administration,
which regulates all
of the companies and the
people who invent and produce
the products that together make
up the biotech world that we
know.
When it came time to deliver
the report to the FDA,
my colleagues and I met with
the commissioner of the FDA
and the top staff of the agency.
On one side of the
table, the IOM committee.
On the other side, the FDA.
Not in an adversarial setting,
but in one of deliberation
where the roles of each side
were clearly delineated.
Here's what I
remember so clearly.
Not a single person on the FDA
side of that table that day
was a man.
Not just the commissioner,
Margaret Hamburg,
but also the various
associate commissioners,
the scientific staff, the
legal staff, and the others.
I wasn't the only
one who noticed this.
As one of my fellow
committee members--
there were several of them-- had
spent a lot of time at the FDA,
he turned to be and said,
20 years ago, Dan, we
would have been sitting
across from a lineup of guys,
and a much less stellar
crew than this one, at that.
I'm not going to
name that gentleman,
but I think he was
probably right.
Now keep in mind this.
The business biotech model
rests and will continue to rest,
no matter what changes happen
under current legislation,
on company sponsors persuading
the FDA that their products are
safe and effective.
Quite beyond the important
ethical, social, and economic
issues at stake today, there
is a business and management
issue.
Unless we think the
gender diversity
has nothing to do with the
ability to make a case,
how sustainable a business
model, how sustainable
an arrangement, is it
for an industry whose
higher echelons are
populated overwhelmingly
by men to make a
business life or death
case to an agency
increasingly staffed
by the best and brightest women?
I'll leave that
for you to ponder.
Our symposium today proceeds
in two parts, the problem
and possible solutions to it.
The first is entitled "Defining
and Analyzing the Problem."
That's the panel to my left.
Then after a break,
"Solutions and Strategies--
What Works and What Has Not,"
followed by closing remarks
by my esteemed colleague,
Janet Rich-Edwards.
To kick off the first panel
on problem definition,
I'm going to turn to
Professor Monica Edwards, who
has written some of the most
insightful early work-- I'm
sorry, Monica Higgins-- on
the early biotech industry.
She is Kathleen
McCartney Professor
of Education Leadership
at the Harvard Graduate
School of Education.
Monica, thank you and welcome
to the Radcliffe Institute.
-Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Good afternoon, everybody.
Good afternoon.
-Good afternoon.
-There we go,
warming ourselves up.
Because we are
all here to tackle
the challenges, the problem,
and to think of some solutions
to move us forward
in this space.
I want to thank the
Radcliffe Institute
for inviting all of us.
Thank you so much.
Looking forward to an
exciting afternoon.
My name is Monica Higgins
I'm a faculty member,
as Dan said, right across the
green there at the Harvard
Graduate School of Education.
Delighted to be here.
You actually have the bios
of the panelists right
in your program, but I'm going
to introduce them very briefly.
And then I'm going to ask
them to introduce themselves
via their ideas
and their work, OK?
So first of all,
immediately to my left
we have Laurel Smith-Doerr, who
is a professor of sociology.
She's also the Director of
the Social Science Research
Institute at the University
of Massachusetts in Amherst,
and she has done some
fabulous research
using lots and lots
of data looking
at academics in science,
and really looking
at gender gaps over time.
I've been an admirer
of her academic work
for a very long time, so we
welcome your large-scale kind
of perspective on this problem.
And then Deborah
Dunsire, who takes
a very different
perspective of course,
because she comes from practice
and has spent years working
in the field in this industry.
She is the President and CEO
of Forum Pharmaceuticals.
And prior to that,
she was the CEO
of Millennium Pharmaceuticals
for many years.
So to say that she
has broken through
is quite the understatement.
So appreciate having you
here, and looking forward so
much to hearing your thoughts
on this problem and just
your own experience as well.
Alison Wood Brooks comes to
us from the Harvard Business
School.
She's a faculty member there.
And she takes a
different approach
to thinking about this.
Her perspective is more of
a psychological perspective.
She studies person
perception, social cognition.
She's very interested in
kind of the early phases
of entrepreneurship-- how do you
get your good ideas out there?
How do you make pitches?
And are there
gender differences?
And while she's not especially
focused on biopharma,
you're going to hear from
her and her research,
and we're going to think
about how her work actually
applies to this, the
complexities of this field.
So she provides a
different angle, as well.
Now, all of us are
taking a learning stance.
And we're here for
different reasons.
I know we have scholars,
practitioners, people
curious in the room.
From my perspective--
so I'm an academic,
but about 10 years
ago I published
a book called Career Imprints--
The Creation of Leaders
Across an Industry.
And I was focused on biotech.
And I looked at how the
health care company called
Baxter Travenol spawned
a disproportionate number
of entrepreneurs, I
argued, at the dawn
of the biotech industry-- so
back in the 1970s, early '80s.
And the thing of it was that
the people I was studying
were all men.
In fact, my colleagues
over at HBS,
where I was before
the ed school,
nicknamed this project
the "Baxter Boys" project.
They're all guys, all men.
And you could say, well, Monica,
this was during the 1970s.
Of course you didn't have very
many women in senior leadership
positions anyway.
And in fact, Rosabeth
Moss Kanter's book,
Men and Women of the
Corporation, came out in 1974.
So OK, maybe there were
some structural barriers
at that time.
But listening to Liz and
thinking about the numbers,
we know that there is
still under-representation.
So the first panel today, we
are really here to try and get
a handle on this.
What are some of the
underlying root causes?
But also just to
understand it better
before we move to
the second session.
So the game is that I am
going to turn the floor over
to our three panelists,
and I'm going
to ask them for
their views on what
is the problem as they see it.
And they will have
15 minutes each.
Some of them have slides and
some don't, and that's fine
and they're welcome up here.
And so they'll have 15
minutes with no interruptions
whatsoever in between--
so no questions at all.
And so we'll just hear
from them back to back.
Then I get a chance to ask
them questions first off.
So I'm probably
going to ask just one
question of each of
them, because we really
want to hear from you.
So the way that's
going to work is
there's a mic right in
the middle of the floor.
And after I ask my
questions-- and that
will take about
10 or 15 minutes--
we're going to
turn it over to you
and you're going to come
to the middle of the floor,
and you're going
to go to the mic
and you're just going to state
your name and your affiliation
and your question.
So for example,
Monica Higgins, I
am a professor at
the ed school, and I
have a question for Deborah.
OK?
That we can get in
a lot of questions.
And then I will signal
when it's the very end,
the last question.
We'll move to a close and then
we'll continue the conversation
over break, OK?
So again, welcome.
Thank you all for being here.
And Laurel, take it away.
[APPLAUSE]
-Great.
So thanks for the
kind introduction,
and thanks to Liz and
Dan for the invitation,
to all the organizers.
I'm really excited
about this event today.
And so I've been invited to talk
about some of my past research
on gender equity in biotech.
I'm a sociologist, so
I'm very interested
in the social contexts in
which people find themselves.
My research has looked at
which social contexts are
conducive to gender equity,
and so I'll talk today
about a sociological
question of where
women find more opportunities
in the life sciences,
looking particularly at
the types of organizations
that are more conducive
to gender equity.
And so it was great
that Liz kicked us
off with thinking
about what's going
on at the very top of
biotech organizations.
I'm going to start by talking
more about what's going on
in the labs and how women have
more authority in certain kinds
of lab settings than others.
And then I'll get to the
question of the leadership
and founders of firms.
So here we go.
Let's see if I can-- great.
So I'm starting from
organizational theory,
particularly from Woody Powell's
contribution, in which he
contrasted forms of economic
organization, two of which
are network organizations
and hierarchies.
So where hierarchy's main
mode of communication
is routines in the network
form, communication
happens through relationships.
Conflict is resolved
in hierarchy
more by rank and authority--
so boss says who wins.
In the network
organizations, it's
more by reputation
and reciprocity.
And where hierarchy
has a more formal tone,
network organizations
are more open-ended
and tend toward
collective benefits
rather than following the rules
to move up the job ladder.
And in the life sciences,
which is where I did my study,
biotech firms that
work on human therapies
are how we measure
network organization--
so the sort of small
entrepreneurial biotech firms--
in contrast to the
more hierarchical,
large, multinational
pharmaceutical corporations
and universities, which
are more hierarchical.
And so the question is, what
does that kind of variation
mean for women in science?
And there are two
different kinds
of hypotheses in the
social science literature,
so it kind of goes both ways.
On the one hand,
there is research
that says bureaucratic
rules are better
for combating discrimination--
so the threat of a lawsuit.
And there's some
research, for example,
on minorities in
the Army that shows
that having a
bureaucratic structure
can actually be good
for racial integration
in large bureaucracies.
On the other hand, social
scientists like Kanter,
who Monica just
mentioned, have long
noted informal organization
does not always
match the formal organization.
So the larger the
bureaucracy, the larger
the shadow side that's cast.
And that can make more room
for informal stereotypes
and sort of the
old boy networks.
So here I was faced with this
literature that said, well,
maybe on the one hand it's
better to have bureaucracy,
and on the other hand
maybe it's better
to have these kind of
network organizations.
So of course, being
a good sociologist,
I turned to the data.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about some data
that I collected long ago,
which began my dissertation.
So I feel like maybe I'm
turning into the historian.
Liz gave us the current stuff
and I'm going back in time,
given that some
of these findings
are now from what
people consider
the early days of biotech.
But the organizers told me
that this context of the past
still has some relevance
for our basic understanding
of social processes and
the theory would still
be interesting and relevant
for our conversation today.
So the first set of
findings I'll tell you about
are for life scientists working
in the 1990s through 2000.
And this is a national
sample of scientists,
and I did a smaller
set of interviews
during that time with scientists
working in the Western United
States.
And then the second set
of data comes from work
that I did with Kristin
Whittington, where she matched
patent data to my sample to
see if we could find a gender
gap in patenting across
the different kinds
of organizational settings.
And then finally, I'll tell you
about a study of Massachusetts
biotechnology firm
founders and leadership
that was sponsored by
the Immigrant Learning
Center in 2007.
They wanted to know about
foreign-born founders,
but they let me add a
question about women
founders in the survey.
So what do I find?
So for the first question, about
what's going on in the labs
and who's really
leading the science,
in these models controlling for
the years since PhD was granted
and the prestige of
the PhD program--
which is a whole other story
that I can answer questions
about-- we can see
the usual gender gap
in hierarchical settings of
academia and the large drug
companies.
Women scientists'
odds of leading a lab
are lower than their
male colleagues.
But women are more
likely to have leadership
roles in biotech firms.
And so I found that the
magnitude of that effect
was quite large, that women in
biotech were almost eight times
more likely to lead
than women PhDs
in more hierarchical
settings like academia
or multinational
pharmaceutical companies.
And there was no
significant difference
for men in the probability
of being the head of the lab
and determining where
the science was going.
All right, and then in terms
of patenting in these analyses
that I did with
Whittington, we found
that patent
productivity in biotech
also exhibited greater
gender equity compared
to more hierarchical settings.
So on these slides-- I don't
know if you can read it
in the back, but the light
grey bar is men's propensity
to patents and the black bar is
women's propensity to patent.
And you can see that there
are large significant gaps
for the large
industrial settings.
That's the first set
of bars, is for pharma.
The second set is government
and nonprofit and research
hospitals.
The third set is academia.
And then the only place
where there's actually
no significant difference-- even
though it looks like women are
out-patenting their
male colleagues,
it's actually not a significant
difference-- there's gender
parity in the biotech firms.
So we can see that
this is a place where
we do find some
gender equity when
we're talking about scientists
who are in the labs.
So I wanted to understand
why this was, right?
Here are these two
different kinds
of organizations, network
organizations and hierarchies.
And what is it that makes for
greater equity in these kinds
of biotech firms?
So I turned to my
interview data and I
identified three
different reasons
why my respondents talked about
the equity in biotech firms.
The first was flexibility.
And so this first quote is
from a female respondent
who had been an academic
and unexpectedly
did not receive tenure,
but was very successful
in biotech management.
And for confidentiality
reasons I cannot identify her,
but you would know her name.
So she is describing how
women are not just forced out
but sometimes voluntarily leave
academe for biotech, at least
in this period during the 1990s.
And a lot of the reasons
why, at least she said,
her women colleagues
left academia
was because they had
more of a choice, more
flexibility in who
they could work
with in the biotech industry.
So here's the quote.
"A friend of mine
left a tenured position at--
I can't say the university--
elite university to
go to a biotech firm.
She called the university
department under--
and she named this guy, which
I don't give his name here--
under so-and-so an autocracy.
She just wanted to do science,
didn't care about the prestige,
and could do science
at the biotech firm
working with who she wanted
to rather than dealing
with this guy.
The second theme that I
heard in many interviews--
so this is just one
example of many interviews
that talked about
the same trend--
was the transparency in biotech.
So this is a quote
from a senior scientist
at a very profitable
biotech firm talking
about her experience
there as opposed
to her academic experience.
She said, "I could tell
you from my experience
in academia many a true story
about political infighting."
And she went on to
give some examples,
which I don't give here.
"At this biotech firm we
are not compartmentalized
and get to work with many
good scientists both here
and outside the
firm, and we choose
who to work with based on
non-financial considerations
like how good they
are in their field."
So these kind of transparent,
permeable boundaries of biotech
seem to shine light
on perhaps some
of the political infighting.
And the reputation that people
have for collaboration matters,
and because of that visibility
that, at least these response
argued, aids in gender equity.
The third kind of theme that
came from the interviews
was about collective rewards.
So this is a quote
that discusses
how collaboration
in biotech also
means that scientists
are rewarded
for their collective
contributions,
that there are some mutual
benefits, which may also
mean some flexibility
for life events.
This particular scientist had
just filed an important patent
and sent off the paper to the
New England Journal of Medicine
the day before she
delivered her baby.
And her project team really
kept her in the loop.
They gained a lot of
resources from it,
but she was part of
that collective reward
that they got for this major
breakthrough that they made.
And doing that
allowed her to have
some social capital
with her collaborators,
and they sort of took up the
slack will she was taking time
off to be with her baby.
So she said, "While I
was on maternity leave
here at this firm I
could keep in touch
with my colleagues who kept
the project moving forward.
And she contrasted
that to academia.
"When I was a postdoc,
people collaborated somewhat
on the fringes of
their work but still
have their main turf, which
they guarded carefully."
So she's contrasting
academic life science,
where collaboration,
sure, it's important,
but the collective
goals and the rewards
are not central to actually
the life of the organization
in the same way that she
identified in biotech firms.
All right, so on to the
question about the founders.
What about the people
who start up firms?
And this was a study,
again, in Massachusetts
with about 300 different firms.
This was research
that I conducted
with Jim McQuaid and Dan
Monte here in Massachusetts.
And what we found--
just in case you're
curious about the
foreign-born founders; that's
another really important kind of
diversity in entrepreneurship.
So here you can see that
that first turquoise
bar is, at the time, the
percent of life scientists
who were foreign-born working
in the US was about 21%.
And 42% of the firms
we surveyed had
at least one immigrant founder.
So here's another data point for
the importance of immigration,
just as a little side note.
And then there's less
gender equity, though,
at the founder level.
In our survey, at least, of
New England biotech firms,
about 21% had at least
one woman founder.
So maybe we're doing
better in New England
than in some other studies.
And so that dark green
bar on the far right
shows that shows that, and
it's in contrast to the taller
dark green bar that shows
that 42% of the national life
science labor force are women.
So women are
underrepresented certainly
in founding biotech
firms, even here.
Although, it's also relative.
There's definitely
room for improvement
in thinking about who are the
founders of biotech firms.
But at least in terms of
patenting and leadership
in the labs, women
life scientists
seem to be finding some ways
that biotech firms allow
for more equity than in
more hierarchical settings.
All right, so I always get
asked, what's going on now?
And so I had the
privilege of being
able to be an outside reader
on a recent dissertation that
was just filed by Janine
Pickering at Swinburne
University in Australia.
And in her research
on Australian biotech
she found much the same thing
that I did in the United States
long ago.
And she actually had
salary data and showed
that there were significant
gender gaps in pay in academia
that were not there
in biotech firms.
She also found authority gaps
like I did in academia, but not
in biotech firms.
Now, the one thing that her
study raised for me, though,
and I think would be
interesting to talk about
maybe during the
later discussion,
is that in both
academia and industry,
she found that jobs were much
more precarious now than they
were at the time I was studying.
So we have fewer
tenure-track jobs.
It's much harder to get them.
I don't have to tell you the
statistics about how long
it takes for life scientists
to get their first NIH
award if they're academics.
And so I think that's
something to think about too,
is the larger political economy
in which biotech is operating.
So just a few thoughts
to end with-- one
practical implication
of this research
is that environment matters.
Organizations that
foster transparency,
collaborative flexibility,
and collective rewards
rather than a rigid chain
of command foster equity
and innovation.
But also, the general
economic climate matters.
If flexibility happens
to mean that none of us
have job security, then
that is not necessarily
a good tradeoff.
Another implication is that
the rules and practices
of organizations should
not be taken for granted
or thought to be genderless.
Awareness matters,
so unconscious bias
flourishes when it's hidden.
And so we need to
be aware of what
the structures are leading to.
And finally, I just
want to make the point
that diversity matters.
Not all women are
the same, and so we
need further support for
foreign-born women scientists.
So in that study of immigrant
founders, almost all of them
were men.
And so I think we
need to think more
about the intersection
of nationality and race
and gender.
So thank you so much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
-Good afternoon, everyone.
It's great to see you here,
and it's a real privilege
and pleasure to be here.
So I'm going to
be talking to you
from maybe the operational
side of the business.
It's so inspiring
and somewhat daunting
to be surrounded by
people who have devoted
their lives to really studying
in-depth and understanding
the detail of the experience
that I simply live day to day.
So I don't offer you
a lot of real data,
but I offer you a lot
of years of experience
of living in the biotech
and pharma world.
And so I think we all know that
there is a paucity of women.
We have many qualified
women, but we don't have them
in the leadership positions.
And it's across the
organizations really,
but goes right from
the board of directors
through the C-suite to
the senior management.
But indeed, not really
at the entry level.
And I'll talk a little bit
about that in different settings
that I've worked in.
I'm one of those people
in pharma and biotech
whose career has sort
of gone backwards,
from working at a very large
company, Sandoz Novartis for 17
years, to a more middle-sized
company, Millennium,
where I was the CEO.
And now I'm at a much
smaller company, FORUM.
So I've gone smaller
and smaller and smaller.
And I do see the differences
for women in those larger
hierarchical organizations.
I was saying, wow, there it is.
It's there.
It's being studying.
And I've lived it.
And when I think about large
organizations like Novartis,
first of all there's
a lot of people.
And in those organizations,
the entry-level
is actually probably
more women than men.
Interestingly, we have to
then start to separate out.
That includes both the
scientific disciplines
and the commercial
and what we call
G&A disciplines, the general and
administration-- finance, HR,
communications.
And when I think about
my own experience,
where the women are,
we're coming more
into those commercial
and G&A disciplines.
And I think, as
you pointed it out,
HR, communications, some of
those entry-level on finance
side-- lots of women.
On the sales side, in the
commercial sales functions
for big pharma-- and
for biotech, by the way,
commercial biotech--
probably more women than men.
And that extends
around the world.
I was on the board of Takeda
Pharmaceuticals in Japan.
And if we think we have a
gender diversity problem,
Japan is truly staggering
for where their women are
versus where our women are.
But even there, the entry-level
for the company at the sales
force side is 52% women.
And so when we look at
the scientific side,
we do see that even
at the entry level
we've got less women
coming into those jobs.
So the sciences are probably,
in big pharma, imbalanced
to the tune of maybe instead of
being 50% it's more like 30%.
And I think that's probably
true in biotech too
when I look at the
entry-level scientists
and I think about who I've
seen in my experience.
So one of the things
we need to understand
is why, even at the entry
level, is that true, where
we know how many women are
qualifying and achieving
at the level that could bring
them into those jobs having
finished-- usually we're
hiring people who've
completed post-docs-- into
those scientific disciplines
in the lab and the clinic.
And particularly in
the lab sciences,
we're seeing less women
at the entry level.
In the clinical disciplines,
actually, it's not true.
So in regulatory affairs,
in clinical development,
pharmacovigilance, we're
actually seeing more women.
You'd probably see
at the entry level,
clinical operations, 60% women.
So there's definitely more of
an issue in my own experience
in those hard science, lab
science, PhD science areas
than there are in the
clinical sciences,
where we're recruiting
people who've
been nurses, people with
bachelor's degrees in biology
into those more
clinical disciplines.
And as we go into biotech, we
do see more women in the labs
and we see more women
rising up in lab management,
but still not at the rate that's
equivalent to their proportion,
even at the entry level.
So there's still a
problem, even in biotech.
But certainly, I can verify
from the operational side
that the research is
absolutely factual.
There's more of a chance for a
woman to lead a lab in biotech
than there is in big pharma.
And that just
exaggerates as we go up.
So then I asked myself,
where are the women?
What's happening to them?
What's taking them
out of the experience?
And I think if I, maybe for
that start at the C-suite,
what takes women
out of the C-suite?
Why don't they get there?
And one of the issues
is where do they
come into organizations, right?
So for an organization,
to run the organization
you've got to have experience
in the mainline functions
of the organization.
And those in a
pharma, in a biotech,
include to some extent
the research, a lot more
the clinical, and
then the financial.
I'd say those are some
of the most critical.
And then, of course,
the commercial.
So some of the
places where women
tend to go in these
organizations--
into communications, HR,
to the general council
or the legal aspect--
are not the paths
that most typically lead you
to have the experiences that
lead to the CEO-level.
It will lead to the
C-suite as the General
Counsel of the Chief
Human Resources Officer,
but it won't take
you to the CEO role.
So what I often find
myself advising women is,
you have to be
doing the work that
is most critical in the
pillars of the corporation.
So figure out where that is.
I think another that
I've observed career-wise
over years of advising women
versus men, because I obviously
have advised lot of men also,
is that women have a tendency
to perfectionism.
And so they want
mastery before they
believe they're ready to
take on something different.
And men don't have the
same need for 100% mastery.
They feel that once they're
at sort of the 80% level
it's time to add more, move
on, get a different experience.
So that for me has been
an interesting observation
of the different genders.
And they're broad
generalizations.
I can only give you
what I've observed,
but they do hold true.
And what that leads to for
women is a couple of things.
One is that they
keep their heads down
and they get the
work done, and they
believe that good work
will be noticed and tapped
on the shoulder.
And believe me, good work
is absolutely noticed,
and people are very
grateful for it.
But it doesn't
necessarily get advanced.
What has to happen is people
have to ask for and make known
their desires for advancement.
And women are much less
comfortable with that,
in general, than men.
They feel, if my boss
thinks I'm good enough,
he'll-- because they're often
"he's"-- will advance me.
And I often say to
them, maybe we need just
to send you out
into the sales force
for awhile to learn that
things don't just happen,
and that the quieter you are,
the more people will believe
you're satisfied
with where you are
and simply leave you there
doing beautiful work that they
love to rely on.
So men will tend to ask more.
The other thing
that I observe is
that women are carrying
often two jobs, right?
They're handling a
lot on the home front
and they're handling a
lot on the work front,
so they tend to come
in, get their work done,
and be going to
relieve the babysitter,
make sure the meal is taken
care of, that their home life is
in order.
And so they don't take as
many opportunities networking.
And I think some of these
are on my next slide,
in the what-do-we-do category.
And so I'll often
advise women, you
do need to be able to devote
time to enabling people
to know you in a setting that
isn't just your single job.
So the concept of
networking-- and I'm
not talking about playing golf.
I'm really talking about
going to industry conferences,
going to industry events, going
to your specialty conference--
whatever it is you're
in, where you'll
meet people who are further
ahead in their journey
in that particular career.
Being in this type
of environment,
there are so many
places where one
can interact with other
people, particularly
in the biotech and
pharma space, who
are at a different
stage of their career.
But you have to be able
to devote some of the time
to that.
And I find that
women versus men tend
to balance their time
differently and balance
their priorities differently,
because we all only have
24 hours in every day.
So I think that's one of
the observations I've had.
I say to people a
lot along the way,
build your base of
experience, and getting
into roles that are
pivotal to the corporation,
externally-facing so
that they do take you out
of the office that
represent the corporation.
And then really, getting
budget-oriented roles--
so owning a budget.
And that's from
various sub-departments
within the big scientific
areas, the clinical ops area--
not only in the
finance area, right?
Those are not the only
people who manage budgets.
So managing budgets
and managing people,
even if they're small groups--
very important experiences.
And then, seek out
those role models
and take advice from them.
I had a thought as you
were talking, Monica,
about the Baxter Boys.
And I don't know
very much about them,
but what flashes into
my mind is once they've
seen one of their
colleagues do it,
it's much easier to
imagine yourself doing it.
And I think that's what we've
had as a difficulty for women,
is they haven't
seen how it's done.
When I came to
Millennium 10 years ago,
I think I was probably
the only female CEO
at that time in
the biotech space--
probably not ever, but
just at that moment.
Now I can count up,
there's probably 11 or 12
that I personally know.
And that creates the
beginnings of the role-modeling
for other women to say,
hey, Nancy Simonian.
She's the CEO at Syros.
I know that she's a doc.
I know that I know her.
I've come across her.
I can go and talk to her.
And seeking that is
really, really, important.
Becoming an external
thought-leader--
if you're in an
organization become
part of your trade association,
your scientific group,
and be a thought-leader.
Become a program advisor or
take on a role that puts you out
in front where your voice is
heard, because people search
on that when they're recruiting
for boards, for lab heads,
for all of those kind of things.
And then, network
across the sectors,
academia to the venture
capital to industry
to the clinical sector.
We've got a unique
ecosystem, but you can't just
stay in your own little world.
Networking across
those-- and there really
are great opportunities
for it here--
I think is important
to broaden the mind
and to help women see what
opportunities are out there.
And I think the other thing
that women don't tend to do
is specifically ask for
advice at a particular time.
Now, I don't think about mentors
as people who are constantly
with you along your career.
That can be so, but often
it's just at a point in time
I'd like to advance my career
from a physician on a project
to a chief medical officer.
Speak to a chief
medical officer.
Ask about their
career progression.
See what you can learn.
So it can be a very time-bound
thing to get mentoring.
And then specifically seeking
board experiences-- again,
sometimes women
wait to be tapped.
But I'd urge people to go out
and ask for what you want.
Speak to people you know who
are running a company and say,
gee, I'm really interested
in being on a board.
Help me understand what would
I have to do to do that.
What are my gaps?
Why isn't it possible for me?
And I find with a
lot of senior women
I have to say to them, gosh,
you're a chief human resources
officer but that isn't what
board governance looks for.
It looks for line experience.
Getting that advice
earlier in her career
might have been pretty
helpful to that lady.
Ask.
Ask the question.
And then for women who
are in the sciences
and who come up with
innovation or patents
or the potential for
patents-- go and seek advice.
Go to a boot camp.
Get some training
in entrepreneurship.
It's out there,
particularly here in Boston.
And then if you have to, learn
by interning-- not giving up
your full-time job,
but offering to help
at a company or a
venture capital firm.
Hey, can I come alongside?
And it is nights and
weekends, and that's sometimes
a problem for women.
But come alongside
and offer to help.
You'll learn while you do it.
So those are some of the
things that I've experienced
over the years that can help.
But I think women need
to express their wants
and be prepared to take that
flier that men are often
prepared to take where
women will shy back from it
and wait to be asked.
Ladies, we can't
wait to be asked.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Hi.
-Good afternoon.
-Yes.
Oh, that's really good.
It is such an honor
and humbling privilege
to be here, following
two academic legends
and an industry legend.
And then there's me.
My name is Alison Wood Brooks.
I am a faculty member
at the Harvard Business
School across the river.
I'm so honored to be here at the
gorgeous Radcliffe Institute.
I've never been here before.
It's just beautiful.
And I've never received such
organized and enthusiastic
emails.
So thank you all
for coming today.
It's a privilege.
Our job on this panel is
to talk about the problem,
so the title of my talk
today is "Why are women
underrepresented as leaders?"
And I'm going to
provide you with two
ideas from my own research.
First, are women really
under-represented
in high-level positions?
We heard some amazing
data from Liz on this,
so I'm going to just repeat
it to make sure that we're all
on the same page.
The answer is yes.
Less than 20% of full professors
in the natural sciences
are women.
Less than 5% of Fortune
500 CEOs are women.
Less than 15% of executive
officers are women.
And less than 11% of US
firms would VC backings--
so that's funding for
their companies-- have
been founded or led by women.
So the answer is yes,
women are underrepresented.
Liz also said an
interesting stat,
that companies that
are lead with three
or more women on their executive
boards tend to perform better.
I have a colleague who's doing
research right now looking
at the board compositions
at Fortune 500 companies
and the gender and
racial compositions.
What she's found is
that there's something
magical about the number
two-- two women on a board.
It's bad to have zero,
because then you're
obviously failing at diversity.
It's bad to have
one, because then you
have the one token woman.
So right now in our
culture the thing
is to have two women
on your board--
so just something
to think about.
OK, so today I'm going
to talk about two ideas
about why we're facing
this gender gap at the top.
And I want to provide
you with a framework
to think about the problem.
It's comprised of two factors.
The first category
of factors I'm
going to call
demand-side factors.
This is how people
perceive and react
to women in the workplace.
A psychologist might call
this interpersonal factors,
how we perceive women
and react to them.
The other category I'm going
to call supply-side factors.
This is what a psychologist
might call intrapsychic.
It's what's going on in
women's minds themselves.
It's how women think and
behave in the workplace.
So I'm going to talk about two
projects, one in each category.
The first falls
into this category
of demand-side factors, how
people perceive and react
to women in the workplace.
So the first paper
asks, is there
gender-based discrimination
in entrepreneurship?
So this is a specific context.
To address this question
in our research,
we analyzed the
entrepreneurial pitches
given at the three largest
entrepreneurial pitch
competitions across the
United States for three years.
Compared to the female
entrepreneurs in our sample,
male entrepreneurs were 60%
more likely to achieve success.
Success meant winning
the competition,
getting funding
for their company.
OK, so it wasn't just
that they were men.
They were also handsome.
OK?
So physically attractive
men were significantly more
likely to get funding than
were the ugly ducklings.
And that's compared
to all women, right?
So physical attractiveness
didn't matter at all
for the women.
It's like you see a
girl pitching a company
and you dismiss her out of
hand because she's a woman,
but then I'm really going
to focus on these men.
When I see the Tom Brady
pitching the company,
that's the winner.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, so this is what we
call correlational data.
It's not causation,
because it's just
observational in the world.
So as scientists, we want
to establish causation.
Is being a man actually
causing you to get funding?
So we wanted to do this
experimentally in the lab
as well, because it's possible
that maybe handsome men really
are better at pitching
their companies.
So let's find out.
We asked six other
people to watch
a series of entrepreneurial
pitch videos
in a controlled
web-based experiment.
And here's how we set it up.
They heard either a female
voice or a male voice
narrating each pitch video.
And we only manipulated
the narrator's gender
by hearing the voice
of a man or a woman,
or their physical attractiveness
because we presented photos
of them, and they were pre-rated
as high or low attractiveness.
And the content of the
pitches was identical.
They saw the same video, the
same images, the same graphs.
The script was identical.
We even trained the vocal actors
to do the same inflections
as they read the pitch script.
And then the participants
chose which company
they wanted to fund with
their own real money.
So they had their
own skin in the game.
Here's what we found--
same pattern of results
as in the entrepreneurial
pitch competition.
When you heard a man
narrating the pitch video
and saw an attractive
photo of him,
people were much
more likely to invest
in that company than when they
saw the ugly duckling male
or what they saw either
an attractive female
or an unattractive female.
So now we've got causal
evidence of this effect.
So here's the summary.
Male entrepreneurs,
especially attractive ones,
are more likely to
receive investor funding
than are female entrepreneurs.
This is based on
their gender and
their physical
attractiveness, and not
on the content of their ideas.
OK, so this is an example
of a demand-side factor.
Here we're seeing very
stark gender discrimination
in entrepreneurship.
When people ask us why
we find these findings,
we've posited that there's
a sort of lack of fit.
When we imagine a
successful entrepreneur,
we imagine a handsome,
assertive man,
and we do not imagine a woman.
This goes back to
Deborah's point.
There just aren't a
lot of role models.
We're not imagining a
woman as an entrepreneur,
and then when we see a
woman pitch a company
there's this lack of fit.
You don't seem like
an entrepreneur,
so I'm not going
to invest in you.
So for the second idea that I'm
going to share with you today
we're going to shift to
the other categories,
supply-side factors.
This is what I called
intrapsychic, in your own mind.
So what's going on
in women's minds?
How does it affect
how they think
and behave in the workplace?
So the second paper
asks, do men and women
view professional
advancement differently?
This paper is coming
out in like two days,
so keep your eyes
peeled in the media.
OK, so I want to do a
little thought experiment
with all of you.
If I asked you,
what are your core
goals in life--
and by core goals
I mean things that
occupy your thoughts,
things that you
deeply care about,
or things that motivate
your behavior and decisions.
So right now just kind of close
your eyes and think about it.
What are your core
goals in life?
If I were to answer this
question I would say something
like, I want to be
a supportive spouse,
I want to take great care
of my six-month-old baby,
I want to successfully
breastfeed,
I want to publish papers,
I want to run every day,
I want to stay fit, I want to
be in fashion and be stylish,
I want to be a good friend,
a good daughter, et cetera.
The list goes on and on.
So we asked a huge sample
of people this question,
and women listed more
goals than men overall.
A smaller proportion
of women's goals
were related to
achieving power at work.
And these findings
held whether people
made a list of their
goals, whether we
asked them to select goals
from a list that we created,
a predetermined list, or
whether we asked people
to reject goals that were
not important to them
from our predetermined list.
So this finding is very robust.
Women are listing
many more things,
and therefore it makes sense
that they have less time
and attention to devote
to any one of those goals,
including their
work-related goals.
This finding is
probably making you
feel a little bit
angry at me, but I want
you to hold onto that anger.
I'm excited to
have a discussion.
OK, so here's the second
part of this paper.
I want you to imagine
you're offered
a promotion for a
higher-powered position at work.
And for the undergrads
in the audience,
imagine that you're offered
a great, high-power position
after graduation.
Now, if I asked you
to rate how much
you expect each
of these outcomes
to come along with that
promotion, what would you say?
We provided these outcomes
to our participants
when they thought
about promotion.
Some of them were negative--
like stress or anxiety,
difficult tradeoffs, burden or
responsibility, and conflict
with other life goals--
and some of them
were positive, like job
satisfaction, money, status,
power.
Here's what we found.
Men and women reported
equivalent levels
of positive reactions.
So men and women are
imagining the same good things
to come out of
high-power positions,
but women are thinking
of more negative things.
Men and women rated the
promotion as equally
attainable-- amazing-- but women
rated the promotion as less
desirable.
This follows logically.
If you're imagining
more negative
outcomes to be associated
with the promotion, the.
Promotion is therefore
less desirable to you.
Compared to men, women are
less likely to actually accept
the promotion
Before I go on, I
just want to say
this was across nine studies
with over 4,000 participants--
women of all different levels.
We had executives
who were currently
in high-powered positions,
average working adults,
and college students,
undergraduate women.
So it seems like a
very pervasive effect.
So there's a big,
fat, juicy disclaimer
that I want to say along
with these findings.
These findings are
descriptive, not prescriptive.
That means that we don't know
if these participants are
right or wrong.
They just are.
These are their
preferences, right now.
It's possible that men
and women are correctly
predicting the unique
experiences they're
poised to encounter when they
reach positions of power,
or women are overestimating
the negative consequences
associated with
power, or men are
underestimating the negative
consequences associated
with power.
We don't know the
answer to that.
It's extremely important.
And I hope that
people in the audience
will do the research to
answer those questions.
OK, so why are women
underrepresented as leaders?
I've provided you with two
ideas here, two examples,
I should say.
One was a demand-side factor.
Entrepreneurs face
gender discrimination.
People are less likely to invest
in pitches given by women.
I also gave you a
supply-side factor example.
Women want different
things in life.
It turns out they want
more things, which
means they have less time
and attention to devote
to their work-related goals.
And it's important to note that
demand-side factors influence
supply-side factors,
and supply-side factors
influence demand-side factors.
They're not independent.
They are inextricably linked.
If I see a high-power
woman being mistreated,
it will make me have
different preferences.
And then how I behave will
influence how people around me
view women generally and
how they react to them.
So that is the end.
I want to say thank you so,
so much to my co-authors
and to all of you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Terrific.
Thank you so much.
I've been taking notes.
I have so many questions.
But I'm going to be brief.
OK, so I'm going to
restrict myself and think
about questions that
cross a little bit, OK?
So starting with Laurel.
So Laurel, I noticed
you were taking notes
throughout as well.
We academics!
But anyway, as you were
listening to Deborah,
some of her arguments have to
do with-- she said pipeline--
but different roles that
individuals, women, take
versus men.
And so I was wondering,
in your own research
or the doctoral
students' research,
whether you saw
differences either
within academia in
particular-- that's
really where a lot of your
work has been-- or biotech.
Because most of your
research was juxtaposing
the two, whether there are
differences within the roles
that people take on and
whether there's anything
we could learn from
there, whether it's
biology versus chemistry.
Are there different
kinds of pieces
to the puzzle that have
to do with roles rather
than the larger
opportunity-structured networks
versus hierarchies
that might lend insight
into the problem from
your perspective.
-And so do you want me to
answer, or are you going to--
-No, I'm going to ask
you to answer that.
Just you, and right now.
-I want to follow the protocol.
Great.
That's a great question.
Thanks.
And I was really fascinated
by Deborah's discussion
about the difference
between line and staff,
which of course is really
important to understanding
who makes it up into
leadership roles.
But something else
that your comments
made me think about,
especially juxtaposing the HR
sort of legal kinds of roles
with the more scientific roles,
is I think really an interesting
question about something
that sociologists study a lot,
which is gender segregation.
And so we know that
occupational segregation
is a huge amount of what
accounts for the pay gap.
And so in my study, which
I should have clarified,
I was looking just
at life science PhDs.
So I was only looking at
people who had their PhDs-- so
comparing people who have
the same qualifications,
and many of whom are from
the same doctoral programs,
in academia and in
pharma and in biotech.
But I think that this question
about how do we segregate--
and it also relates to what
Allison was just saying,
about how do we
self-segregate too.
So there's a lot of
interesting research.
For example, a study by a
sociologist, Maria Charles,
that finds that in international
studies of how do women
choose majors.
In less developed
countries, women
are much more likely to go
for engineering and natural
sciences.
But when there's
more of a choice,
that's when women choose
to go into social sciences
and humanities.
And so there's something about
the structure in which we're
making our choices and sort
of self-segregating that
needs further examination,
is what I would say.
-Great.
Thanks.
Very helpful.
Deborah, I can't help
but ask the question
with the setup and
the introduction
that we had about the optimism.
And you are clearly
somebody who's optimistic.
And yet also, listening
to Allison, and even
your own remarks about
women not seeking
out help,
self-sponsorship, or seeing
the negative side and so forth.
And I know this bleeds over
into the second session,
so I apologize.
But I know that's where you're
at and what we can learn from.
What are your thoughts
on maintaining
that optimism, first of
all, which clearly you have?
And secondly, do you see
changes over the years?
Are you optimistic, I guess?
-Well, I think I'm an
optimist by nature,
so let's just say that.
But I do see changes
over the years.
And one of the changes that
I am really encouraged by--
and I'm not sure it's getting
exactly to this panel--
is the change in young men.
And young men--
young compared to me,
not necessarily that young--
are much more interested
in balanced life.
I'm seeing more young men who
will want the type of work that
allows them to do
some of the things
with their family that make them
say, no, I don't necessarily
just want a bigger job.
I want to be a part
of my children's life.
And also, in that
upcoming generation,
there are more families with
two working spouses where
tradeoffs have to be made.
And it's not always the
woman who's trading anymore,
as it used to be maybe
at least 20 years ago.
That's definitely
evolved over time.
So I think we're
moving into a time
where both women and men
might have-- unfortunately,
your research is
making a liar of me--
that maybe women and men are
going to have more goals.
And it was so interesting.
Your work is so interesting.
And it resonates with
me, because I think about
and I think of the
context in which men
make those decisions
often is the context of,
yeah, I can think
about the upsides
because I'm not trading
away as many downsides,
because there's somebody else
in my life who takes care
of making sure my kids are great
and everything's functioning
and they're getting
fabulous input.
I feel like our family
ecosystem, together
with my often non-working
spouse and me, is stable,
so they can focus on much more
so-- pop psychology, probably.
And you can all criticize
me, but I'm not the academic.
And maybe it will shift
a bit more over time.
And I think women are-- I've
made decisions in my career
where I wouldn't go
for the bigger job
because of the mother
I wanted to be-- not
because my husband isn't
fabulously supportive
and absolutely would have
helped me make it happen,
but because of who I wanted
to be for my children.
So commuting-- we want to
keep our high-schoolers in one
place, and many people-- never
mind just men, men and women--
will make a decision to commute.
I didn't want to,
and it was nothing
to do with my husband
and his support.
So I don't feel
victimized or put upon.
It was me.
I wanted to be there.
So yes, we do make decisions
with the broad set of goals,
and keeping what
we want in balance.
I just feel that's great.
So I want women always to feel
empowered to make the decision.
There's no absolute need to
always want the bigger job.
But if you want it, we need
to create the ecosystem where
you can go for it as a woman.
And it's not just going to
be your voice or your looks
or your gender that
has you dismissed.
-It takes a village, really.
Alison, I know you haven't done
work specifically in this area,
but now you've been thinking
about the particulars.
And I'm just wondering
if you can just
riff with us a little bit.
If you've thought about
the wonderful social-psych
experiments that you've seen
or you've done yourself,
is there anything
about this context
that you can think about
that might particularly
put kind of an accent at the
end of some of your results?
Or maybe it isn't quite
so stark in this context.
And we know you're not
specifically studying this,
but we'd still love to hear
the benefits of your thinking
as you're absorbing this.
-Absolutely.
I think the entrepreneurship
findings are particularly
relevant for this
audience, because I
think the effect would be
particularly strong in contexts
that are sort of hard sciences.
There's a lot of math,
complexity, uncertainty.
It's in contexts like that
where these quick, go-to
discriminatory rules,
people use them more often.
So for example, imagine a woman
is pitching a makeup company.
People would be more
likely to listen
to her in that
context as opposed
to pitching some pharmaceutical
drug or another biotech type
of idea that one might
say traditionally
or historically is a sort
of male-typed context.
The lack of fit between the
entrepreneur and the content
is even more dramatic.
But that means that the
opportunity to be a badass
and be a star in those
domains is even larger.
-Excellent.
Another optimist on the panel.
OK, we turn now to you
for your questions.
So just line up
right at the mic.
Make sure you just state
your name, your affiliation,
and you can direct your
question to one or more
of our panelists.
Thank you.
-I'm Joanne Kamens, the head of
Addgene, a nonprofit biotech.
So I've been able to take
both my woman's desire
to do woman-like nonprofit-y
things and lead a biotech.
So finding that middle balance.
Alyson, I guess this
is mostly for you,
but I think for
all the panelists--
I was very interested
in everything you said,
but the intersection
between this supply-side
and the demand-side factors.
So I speak to hundreds of
women scientists every year.
I do career speaking
for postdocs.
And my question is, the implicit
bias toward how women should
behave as moms and as women--
speaking quietly, politely,
raising their children as
the primary parent, all
those things-- is that affecting
women's desires, do you think?
Or is it women's desires
that are the problem?
So we say to women, you
need to learn how to golf.
You need to ask.
We have to ask more.
We have to do all these
things to overcome the bias.
But has the bias caused-- like,
am I supposed to feel guilty?
I don't.
Maybe that's why I've been
successful in my career.
I've got a husband.
He can do half.
But so many women I know, they
feel guilty and the men don't.
Even the ones who are
starting to contribute 50-50,
they don't feel guilty.
Is that society telling
us, or is that how we are?
-Thank you.
-That's such a deep question.
I wish I knew the answer.
I think my intuition is
that the bias is making
us feel that way, because
this research is a snapshot
of our culture right now.
And if we were to run those
same studies 50 years ago or 50
years from now, I
think and hope that we
would have found very
different results 50 years ago,
and I hope that we find
different results in 50 years.
Right now I think we're still
in a time of cultural shift
gender-wise.
It was not that
long ago that women
could be nurses or teachers or
nothing, or a stay-at-home mom.
So I think we're still
in a dramatic time
of cultural shift,
and right now I
think the guilt that women
feel is likely a result of bias
and not the other way around.
But I think that the
scientifically correct answer
is we don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
-Hi, I'm Jenny [INAUDIBLE], and
I'm actually a psychologist.
I run my own talent management
and executive coaching firm,
and I'm actually in the
process of conducting
some qualitative research
right now with rising
women scientists, because I do
a lot of coaching in this space
and have seen a lot
of women feeling stuck
at that middle management
level-- so looking
at some of these factors.
And Alison, my question is for
you, because your comment about
do they want to get
to that next level
is one of the questions
I'm looking at,
motivating and
demotivating factors
as well as organisational
systems that support or impede.
And part of what I'm
hearing is the women
say they want influence, they
want to expand their impact,
they want to do good
work and feel satisfied,
but they are very concerned
about the tradeoffs.
They are concerned about
the work-life balance.
And my question for you
is, in your research,
did you find any
age-related changes?
So in the 20s, are the concerns
less in terms of the negatives?
Are they a little
bit less worried
about the time factor, the
travel issues, et cetera.
-Great.
Excellent.
And I'd love to hear from
Deborah on this, as well.
Do you want to go
first, Deborah?
-No, go right ahead.
-So we had the same
hypothesis, which
is why we went after high-level
executives, working adults,
and college kids-- I'm
sorry, college students.
And we thought that
college students would
have more progressive
views, and maybe they
hadn't been infiltrated
by biases quite yet.
But it seems like we
didn't even go young enough
with our sample.
Even college
students are thinking
ahead to what's my life going
to be like as a working adult.
In fact, I think women
in college in particular,
it's really on their
minds about how am I
going to be a
high-powered CEO and have
a beautiful, wonderful family?
And I don't think the answers
are clear, probably because
of what Deborah was saying.
There aren't a lot
of role models.
-Yeah.
I think that is
exactly right, and I
think that what I often have
to say to people is they say,
I want to be home
with my family.
I don't want to take a
job in another city that's
better, because I've got
my support systems here.
And that's great and fine,
but what I counsel them is you
need to own up to
what that costs you.
You can't ask to have the same
experience at the end of it
as the man, often, who
has made those moves,
has gathered those extra
experiences, has been out there
being a thought-leader,
being prepared
to travel on the weekend.
So you will be very delayed.
So when your kids
are self-sufficient
and you want to do
that, you will not
have the experience base.
So let's just all be clear about
that, because it is in that way
a meritocracy-- not
exclusively; there are biases.
But at a minimum, the women
have to have to the same levels
of experience.
You can't do it with less.
-Thank you.
Yes?
-Hi.
Good afternoon.
Thanks for being
with us here today.
My name is Zachariah
[INAUDIBLE],
and I am a master student
at the Harvard Graduate
School of Education.
Prior to coming to HGSE, I was
an early childhood teacher,
teaching primarily pre-K and
K. And I saw in the classroom
how both boys and
girls already had
such a strong socialized
sense of gender norms,
whether it's this color is for
girls or boys can't play this,
or you can't play with me
because you are a boy or girl.
I was mindful of
these, and I always
struggled with how to
effectively encourage
the right kinds of
interpersonal skills
so that when they grew up, both
genders would have a chance
to succeed professionally.
I really had that
in mind long-term.
So my question is, what
specific interpersonal skills
and internalisation are
necessary for young girls
to be able to succeed
in the workplace?
-Thoughts on that?
-I'll dive in.
-Yeah.
-I think one of
them is confidence
and being able to speak up.
What I find with
women frequently
is that they will offer
a perspective in almost
an apologetic way.
Sometimes there's
a physical apology.
I had to take one
woman aside and say,
stop presenting like this.
Stand up and face your audience.
And so there's
physical attributes
that come along with it.
There's vocal and
verbalization attributes.
Women will say "I feel."
Men will say "I
think" or "I know."
And I don't know
where those come from,
but they're pretty prevalent.
So I think that
confidence, the ability
to speak clearly and
articulately in a debate,
and to take on conflict--
not in a combative way,
but to feel comfortable
defending a point of view.
Now, I'm talking to
rooms full of PhDs
who've all defended
dissertations,
so you know how to do that.
But in an argument where
you're not the expert
necessarily, how do you
feel comfortable holding
onto a point of view?
How do you feel comfortable
insisting on being heard?
Because women will
often back off when
somebody interrupts them.
Men simply either don't
allow it to happen
or will come back at it.
So there are, I think,
behaviors that we
can help our young women right
from the very elementary learn,
and practices that we can
teach them to help them.
It can't overcome all the
bias, but it can sure help.
-Laurel has some thoughts.
-I'm working on
a paper right now
in the chemical
sciences that looks
at lab presentations of
graduate student men and women.
And we found a very large
crisis of confidence
in the women graduate students.
But the context matters, right?
And so we find that the PIs
are interrupting the women
and helping them,
answering for them.
They don't do that
for the male students.
There's also this
joking manner that they
have with the male students,
like, oh, you know.
It's very light.
And it's very serious
for the women students.
And so the situation, the
interactional situation,
is different for
the women students
than it is for the men.
So I would say
that teachers maybe
need to think about
what kinds of classroom
contexts they're creating, that
it's not just on the students.
So I come from Amherst,
and in our public schools
there, which are very
gender non-normative place
in Massachusetts.
The boys and girls play
soccer together all the way
through elementary school,
and that's not in all places.
So if you have less gender
segregation at the early level,
I'm curious to see what happens.
I'm hoping those
girls will then be
able to forge new
paths later on, too.
So thanks for your question.
-Helpful, thank you.
-Thank you.
-And I'm going to ask you
guys to keep it brief,
because we're
clicking down on time
and I see a long line there.
-OK, I'll try to be brief.
[INAUDIBLE]
I'm in the private sector in
a hierarchical environment,
so I see that perspective.
And so my question
is for Deborah.
Monica said that it
requires a village.
But before it
requires a village,
we've identified
who it requires.
It's the people in power
in the hierarchical.
That's where the
majority of the jobs are.
But when we look who's
here, they're not here.
So how do we get
them to be engaged
in part of this conversation?
-Some of us are here.
Just because [INAUDIBLE]
doesn't mean we're not here.
-I think the question is that
the male CEOs of corporations,
why are they not here?
And I think they
are being alerted
to it and within their own
companies need to take action.
So I think what we need to go
do is go to the business sector
and have the same kind of
meetings within the business
sector as well so that we're
attacking it on all levels.
-Great, thank you.
Yeah?
-Hi.
My name is Anna Ward,
and I was most recently
senior vice president and
general counsel of a company
where I also headed HR-- so up
through the pink career ladder.
I love pink, by the way.
But because I hit
the ceiling as GC
and they wouldn't allow me to
get operational experience,
which is a problem.
I'm going to launch
my own company here
as an entrepreneur.
And so Alison, your
data, though interesting,
doesn't offer any solutions
other than to hire
a hot young guy, which I'm
totally open to, by the way,
OK?
I'm just saying.
-I can just see the
Twitter feed light up.
-And I believe it.
I don't doubt that
there's a problem,
but I want to focus
on those solutions.
And so what I would ask is,
what would you advise me,
as a female entrepreneur
launching a company here
in Boston?
-Hire a hot young guy.
No.
No, it's an excellent question.
This is the question
that keeps me up at night
and why this type of research
is slightly dissatisfying,
because it's easy to
identify problems.
It's a lot harder to
identify solutions.
I'm going to punt
that that question,
because the next panel is
talking all about solutions
to these kinds of problems.
-We probably also need other
people on the other side.
I noticed in your
picture all the judges--
-Correct.
-Unless that just
happened to be the case?
-My name is Cassandra Smith.
I'm founder of Athena Biomedical
Research Organization focused
on prevention of mental
illness through nutritional
interventions and with
early detection of inborn
errors of metabolism.
And I don't know
why I'm so nervous.
-You're among friends.
-My question-- and some
of this is anecdotal,
but I noticed that
there were very few
American women who were on the
editorial boards of journals.
And what do I want I
say American women?
Like third, fourth,
et cetera generations.
Most of this is
anecdotal observations,
but when Dan Koshland was
chief editor of Science,
he had 100 people on
the editorial board.
90 were men.
10% of those were at
foreign institutions.
He had 10 women.
90% of those were at
foreign institutions.
So that kind of says to me,
are these men in science,
they can deal more easily
with these foreign women.
And I've seen it in
other situations.
Are they doing this because it's
easier to deal with these women
than to deal with us?
-Wow.
-So there's work
by Katrina Zippel,
who is an expert sociologist
at Northeastern here.
And she's done some work that
looks at the intersection
of nationality and gender.
Her research shows
some of what you're
saying, that the
interaction context is very
different for women who are
from foreign countries who
are scientists than for
domestic women scientists.
It's real.
-I think that's somehow
how people are interacting.
One fast question--
what about tallness?
-What about what?
-Tallness.
Height.
-I'm so fascinated by height.
-I've actually noticed
this in biotech.
[INAUDIBLE]
-Very high heels.
No, I know.
It's a variable that
actually could matter a lot.
We haven't even
looked at that yet.
-Great, thanks.
-Hi.
My name is Laurel Wright.
I'm a PhD student
in biology at MIT.
And Deborah, some of the
characteristics and actions
that you were talking about--
when I think about that
anecdotally, some of these
badass women, I think,
sometimes are perceived
differently than men who--
-Are badass.
And I was wondering
from the sociologist
if there are data that
kind of support that idea.
Women who have these
certain characteristics,
are they discriminated
against in a different way
than men who have the same
kind of characteristics?
-Alison, you might
want to take this.
There's lab studies on it.
-Yeah.
First I want to say that
truly badass women who
make it to the top get a
sort of perceptual boost.
Because people
realize that they've
navigated all of these landmines
and persisted and succeeded,
there is actually a boost
in respect and perceptions
of competence for women who
can go and pitch their ideas
and succeed and women
who kind of navigate
their way through
all of these biases
and discriminatory things.
There is a lot of
research about backlash
is what you're describing.
Women who display agentic
or assertive behaviors
are seen as bitchy
and cold, and men
who displayed agentic
and assertive behaviors
are seen as leaders.
This is the sort of baseline
type of gender research
that we know is happening
right now in our culture.
-Deborah, have you
seen this work?
You clearly have.
So thinking about
the social context
in which women are displaying
agentic and assertive
behaviors, what are the
conditions under which
that actually does work?
Because it's clear
that a lot of people
here are thinking
about how either we
can create the context,
as my sociologist friend
here would say, or how
can we change behavior,
as my social psychologist
friend would say?
So I'm just wondering if you've
seen the marrying of the two
and under what conditions.
-I think the answer is not
going to help a whole lot,
and where I see
it function based
is when you get past the
tipping point in organizations
where there's not that
tiny minority of women.
So when there's more of a
balance within organizations,
you see that there's the
same spectrum of women
as there are of men in
terms of their behavior.
Sometimes somebody who's
outspoken and assertive
is a bitch, excuse me.
Others are not.
And it's the same with men.
Some of the assertive
behaviors are actually
very productive and
functional, and some of them
aren't in organizations.
But you can only see that and
not get the one generalization
when there's more of a balance.
So finding a place, when
you're examining potentially
a career in industry,
being in a place
and actually observing
what is the gender balance.
You're more likely to be able
to manifest those behaviors
without as much backlash if
there is more gender balance
within the organization.
Just as a
top-of-my-head comment.
-Thanks.
Great.
-Hi.
My name is Renee [INAUDIBLE].
I'm head of research
at a small biotech
here in Cambridge that focuses
on biological data sciences.
And this has been
very engaging and has
gotten me thinking about the
constitution of the management
team of my company over the last
10 years that I've been there.
And it's gone from 0% women to
50% women, which is fantastic.
I think it's a very
meritocracy-driven
organization.
There have been five women
on the management team.
And one of the things that I
noticed was out of this five,
four of us have come
up through the ranks.
So we started at
entry-level positions.
And my question is really, is
that a requirement for women
in leadership positions?
Must we demonstrate
our capabilities
within the organization in
order to attain that level?
-I'm trying to think
through very quickly
my experience of the
women that I know that are
in very senior positions.
And I think there are a
predominance of them that
have been with the
companies long time,
but there are definitely more
in the last maybe five years
that have been hired
in from the outside.
So perhaps that's in my teeny,
tiny, insignificant data
sample.
There's a bit of a shift
that women can actually
move now into those more
leadership positions.
I actually did a study on this
same topic about 10 years ago.
From our ranks, there were
hundreds of women there.
And I led a study
because no women
were getting promoted into group
leader positions from within.
They were all being
hired from without.
And we did a study,
both a perception
study, only on one
company, and actually
looking at the numbers.
And the reasons turned out to be
that if you came into a company
when you were early
in your career
and you didn't display the
features that we needed,
you were remembered
as that little girl.
No matter you had
accomplished, the perception
was you were still that
little girl that you
came in as 10 years
ago, and you were never
going to get promoted.
so you were never going to
get promoted from within.
And all of these
women were being
hired from without
until we pointed it out.
And leadership changed some of
their criteria for promotion
and attempted to put in some
transparency and bureaucracy
to allow women to be
promoted from within.
And two women were then the year
later promoted to group leader.
But we had to demand
it-- demand it.
-Provide evidence.
Yeah, great question.
-Hi.
I got the height gene, lucky me.
So I'm Lisa Levy.
I'm a long-term
diversity consultant
with a lot of deep expertise in
gender norms and gender roles.
So my question is, why don't
we ever ask about why men say,
I can't be the
father I want to be?
It's amazing that that's not
a part of our conversation
even all these years in, because
even if you have someone else
doing it all,
you're not doing it.
And you can only get that
one-on-one even more so,
I would argue, with your family
than what you could do at work.
So that's a question I'd
just love your feedback on.
And the second question is,
what responsibility do you
think men have given we know
organizations are profoundly
privileged towards men?
We wouldn't have the
data over all the years,
and that's not changing
at the very top.
What responsibility do you
think men have to be allies
or to do something proactively
to make it more equitable?
-So I'm going to
give our panelists
the choice of answering
one of your questions.
I think the first
one may be broader
than perhaps this panelist
would even choose to speak to,
but you have the choice if you'd
like to address one of them.
-I'll address the first one.
-Excellent.
-So masculinity studies
show that the male gender
role is a lot stricter than
the female gender role.
So girls can be tomboys,
but boys can't be sissies.
And so transgressing
that, there's
a lot more punishment
that men face.
And so I think that's also
true for fatherhood probably
as well, that transgressing
the work role--
-The second one
I'll be very brief.
I think the
responsibility for men
is a responsibility
to the business.
And I'll come back to the
performance of companies.
This is not a fairness issue.
It's not a politeness.
This is a business issue,
diversity of all types.
Gender diversity, racial
and ethnicity-- we have to,
as business leaders, do that.
And I think that case has not
been sufficiently persuasively
communicated.
-Excellent.
Thank you.
We have time for
one more question.
OK?
So you are on.
-I'll be quick.
-Thank you.
-My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a stem cell
biologist at Harvard.
I'm a postdoc.
My question is for Laurel.
It's regarding this networks
and the hierarchy thing.
So I definitely work
better in a team.
So my question is, do
we not like hierarchies,
or is it that we never got to
the really powerful positions?
-Good question.
Yeah, I think it looks
pretty good from the top
when you're in a
hierarchy, right?
And I don't think it's anything
that's essential to women,
that they're more collaborative.
That's not something, at least
that I've found in my research.
But that more
collaborative structure
allowed for more gender equity.
And maybe it's because of the
broader culture that we live
in, but I like your question.
Sounds like an area
for future research.
So I'd like to
thank our panelists.
[MUSIC PLAYING]